Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Guten Abend Herr Doktor.
Ich heiße Fukanbaran und bin auf dieser Station als Diensthabender.
Herr Doktor, ich habe den Namen nicht ganz verstanden. Wie heißen Sie sie nochmal genau?
Ich heiße Fukanbaran.
Doktor Bargan ist richtig?
Bargan. Mit A.
Bargan.
Wie schreibt ich das, damit ich es mit notieren kann, damit ich weiß, mit wem ich gesprochen habe?
B, A, L.
L?
R.
R, Bar.
A, N.
Baran.
Ja, genau.
Doktor Baran, alles klar. Hab ich mir notiert.
Ja, guten Abend Doktor.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen diese Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Als erstes werde ich ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Harald Münchhausen.
Herr Münchhausen, können Sie Ihre Vornahme und Nachname langsamer stabilen?
Vornahme ist Harald.
H, A, R.
A, L, D.
Harald.
Und Nachname ist Münchhausen.
M, I, N.
C, H, A, U, S, E, N.
Münchhausen.
Harald Münchhausen.
Richtig.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin das 30 Jahre alte Doktor.
Und wann wurden Sie gebrochen?
15 Zentimeter mehr als 93.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Wie viel wie viel?
70,5.
Und ich bin 1,75 Meter groß.
Und Herr Münchhausen, haben Sie eine Hausarztin?
Ja, habe ich.
Dr. Müller.
Okay.
Herr Münchhausen, was hat Sie so uns geführt?
Herr Doktor, ich habe verschiedene Probleme.
Wie fange ich am besten an?
Ich habe mich in den letzten 3 Monaten ungefähr 1,5 kg abgenommen.
Und das kommt mir sehr bedrohlich vor.
Das ist eines der Probleme.
Dann habe ich manchmal Schweißausbrüche.
Dann rast mein Herz ganz schnell.
Aber der Hausarzt hat mein Herz schon untersucht.
Da habe ich jetzt keine Probleme.
Sie haben Herzrasen, oder?
Ab und zu habe ich Herzrasen.
Aber nicht immer.
Dann habe ich noch Probleme mit dem Rückenschmerzen.
Und ich hatte jetzt vor ungefähr 10, 14 Tagen eine Göttelrose.
Das hat mich sehr beunruhigt.
Ich wollte das jetzt noch mal schauen.
Ich habe auch Kopfschmerzen.
Wenn ich mit dem Handy telefoniere, habe ich auch Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe die Befürchtung, dass ich eine Krankheit habe.
Herr Münchhausen, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Sind alle Beschwerden gleichzeitig anfangen?
Ja, sie sind unterschiedlich.
Ungefähr seit einem halben Jahr habe ich diese Beschwerden.
Ich habe natürlich eine Befürchtung, dass es eine schlimme Krankheit sein könnte.
Das ist meine Befürchtung.
Letztes Jahr habe ich meine Mutter verloren.
Es wird mir sehr leicht machen.
Ich habe die Kleoplasturma-Multiforme gestorben.
Mein Vater ist leider vor ungefähr 3 Jahren in Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Ich habe jetzt die Befürchtung, dass ich eine ähnliche Krankheit habe.
Ich habe sie sehr gut verstanden.
Ich habe die Göttelrose jetzt richtig Angst bekommen.
Ich habe gelesen, dass das als Vorstufe von Krebs oft gesehen wird.
Ich möchte sie beruhigt werden.
Diese Beschwerden kommen nicht immer mit einer schlechten Krankheit.
Nach diesem Gespräch und nach unserem Untersuchungen
können wir genau das darüber sprechen.
Sie haben seit 3 Monaten eine Gewichtsabnahme von 1,5 kg.
Sie haben auch eine Herzrasen seit 6 Monaten.
Sie hatten manchmal rückensche Mersen und koffschmerzen.
Sie leiden unter einem Schweißausbrüche.
Seit 10 bis 15 Tagen leiden Sie an einem Göttelrose.
Ja, richtig.
Haben Sie einen Luftnot?
Luftnot habe ich nicht.
Sind Ihnen schwindig oder übel?
Wenn ich eine Herzrasen habe, wird mir auch übel.
Haben Sie einen Röschen?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Haben Sie eine Schmerz an der Rücken?
Ja.
Können Sie genauer sagen?
Im unteren Rückenbereich.
Sie sind in einer Lebenserscheinung.
Haben Sie einen Röschen?
Nein, ich habe einen Röschen.
habe ich nicht gemerkt, Doktor?
Also, oder bei Pohla gerung der Oberkörper oder also, das ist etwas Auslöse für diese Bescheide, wissen Sie?
Aber jetzt muss ich bei Krebs ja auch nicht sein, habe ich gelesen, ja?
Okay.
Können Sie Ihre Rücken-Schmerzen genauer beschreiben, also pochen, hemende oder sichende Schmerzen, was gehen Sie?
Sie werden eher so dumpfer schmerzen, ja.
Und schmieren Sie diese Schmerzen irgendein Felschikörpere, also zum Beispiel Beinen oder Beinen oder...
Nein, wir sind immer rücken nur.
Okay. Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala, wenn eins leichter und zehn unerträgliche Schmerzen sind?
Also, manchmal so acht bis neun, würde ich sagen.
Manchmal acht bis neun.
Ja.
Was haben Sie dagegen gemacht?
Da habe ich jetzt verschiedene Schmerzmettikramente, zuletzt habe ich von meinem Haus aus, Doktor Müller habe ich Tramadolol bekommen.
Tramadol.
Ja.
Und wie viel Milligramm?
Ja, das sind, zum Mund gucken wir in der Packung, nach 150 Milligramm Rettat, die nehme ich morgens und abends.
Nehmen Sie diese Medikamente regelmäßig ein oder...?
Im letzten Tagen, ja.
Okay.
Und fühlen Sie sich heiser als sonst, also, oder haben Sie eine Fieber bemerkt?
Ne, Fieber habe ich nicht, Herr Doktor, nein.
Nur Schweißausbrüche habe ich, wie ich schon gesagt habe.
Aber auch nicht jeden Tag, das kommt und geht.
Okay.
Und schützen Sie in der Nacht aus?
Auch?
Auch, ja.
Und, Herr Müntmutscher, haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt, vielleicht, wo diese Schmerzen aufgetreten sind?
Kann mich nicht erinnern, Herr Doktor, ich habe keinen Unfall gehabt, nein.
Okay.
Und, haben Sie, wie ist Ihr Schlaf, also, haben Sie eine Schlachtstörung gern?
Ja, ich kann nicht gut schlafen, also, weil...
Ich rieche auf.
Man weiß nichts, also, sehr unruhig nachts.
Oder müssen Sie in der Nacht schon Toilette gehen?
Ja, manchmal aber nicht immer, aber ich schlafe unruhig.
Ich wache dann alle, ein, zwei Stunden auf.
Und Sie haben mir gesagt, Sie, dass Sie eine Gewichtsabnahme,
Gewichtsabnahme leidet.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit, ernähren Sie Sie Hausgewogen, oder?
Ja, ist ein bisschen weniger als sonst, ja.
Weniger ist sonst auch.
Warum haben Sie weniger Appetit?
Was liechsen Sie ein oder was denn darüber?
Ich habe gelesen, dass es oft auch ein Symptom ist von solchen Krankheiten, ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Sturrgang?
Ja, ich habe Verstopfung eigentlich, ja.
Verstopfung?
Ja.
Und seit wann haben Sie Verstopfung?
Also, mein Arzt hat auch gesagt, diese Schmerztabletten machen auch Verstopfung,
hat er mir gesagt, deswegen glaube ich, dass es von den Schmerztabletten kommt.
Okay.
Und ich trinke auch wenig, vielleicht nichts auch daran.
Und wie viel mal gehen Sie zum Toilette, also, zum Sturrgang?
Ach so, so sagen Sie.
Ja, so, jeden zweiten, dritten Tag.
Jeden zweiten, dritten Tag.
Ja.
Okay.
Und wie sagt Ihr Sturr aus, können Sie es beschreiben?
Also, wie ist Ihr Konsistenz oder Farbe?
Ja, fast, aber sonst von der Farbe, ich würde sagen, ein normaler Sturrgang, ja.
Haben Sie Blut bemerkt oder?
Hab ich geguckt, aber ich habe keinen Blut gesehen zum Glück, ja.
Also, ist das schwarz oder?
Nein, nein.
Normal.
Und husten Sie?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Hatten Sie solche Beschwerden schon einmal oder waren Sie deswegen beim anderen Arzt?
Ja, also, ich hatte vor halbem Jahr auch schon mal wieder so ein bisschen Gewicht abgenommen,
dann war ich auch mal im Kargen aus, dann haben die auch CT-Untersuchungen gemacht.
Und jetzt habe ich auch Angst, dass von diesen Röntgenstrahlen auch vielleicht etwas ausgelöst werden könnte.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sehr man kann das Röntgenstrahlen auch klebs verursachen können.
Ich weiß nicht, was Sie denken, Herr Doktor?
Ja, während der Kompetenzimmografie bekommen Sie nur wenige, nur wenige geringe Röntgenstrahlen.
Also, es ist gleich wie ein Transatlantik-Flug.
Deswegen machen Sie keine Sorge dabei.
Ich habe mich jetzt geärgert, weil ich hätte vielleicht doch nicht waren sollen CT-Untersuchungen.
Jetzt ärgere ich mich, weil ich jetzt vielleicht dann einen Schaden durch diese Röntgenstrahlen bekommen habe.
Aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe, während der Kompetenzimmografie bekommen Sie nur wenige, wenige Röntgenstrahlen.
Herr Mumschausen, leiten Sie eine irgendwelche chronische Erkrankung, also wie so eine Krankheit oder Bluthochdruck?
Nein, ist nichts bekannt, aber ich habe erwartzt und da habe ich auch gelesen, dass das auch Virusinfektionen sind, die auch Krebs verursachen können.
Diese Apilomaviren habe ich gelesen.
Was denken Sie, Herr Doktor?
Ich habe am Anfang nicht verstanden. Können Sie es wiederholen?
Ich habe Wartzen, Delwa-Wartzen.
Da habe ich gelesen, dass das von Virusinfektionen kommt, von Papillomaviren.
Die werden auch immer genannt bei Krebserkrankungen, dass die Krebs auslösen können.
Ich habe wenige Erfahrungen dabei, aber ich werde für Sie über diese Themen mit unseren Dermatologen sprechen.
Das wäre nett. Danke schön, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe dieses auch aufschritten geschrieben.
Und gibt es noch etwas?
Vor zwei Jahren hatte ich auch Covid, war auch schwer bei mir Covid.
Ich habe auch einen Bekanntenkreis, der nach der Covid-Infektion auch Lungkrebs bekommen hat.
Das hört man zunehmend, dass diese Corona-Infektionen Krebs auslösen können.
Vielleicht haben Sie die Erfahrung aus Ihrem Klinikalltag.
Es gibt noch wenige Recherche, darüber, dass Covid und Lungkrebs keine Abhängigkeit gibt.
Deswegen machen Sie, wie ich gesagt habe, keine Sorge.
Sie sind in einem Krankenhaus und ich werde Sie sehr gut, ich werde Ihnen sehr betrohnen.
Danke, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe ein gutes Gefühl über die
Krankheiten und Symptomen.
Ich habe gesagt, meine Mutter ist gestorben, ein Krebserkrank.
Der Bruder von Vater hatte auch Magenkrebs und meine Tante hatte auch Brustkrebs.
Ich habe mich gefützt, dass meine Gene ein Risiko haben.
Ich möchte Sie wieder beruhigen.
Die Krebskrankheiten sind nicht 100% erheblich.
Wir wollen erst die Aufnahme und unsere Untersuchungen zu Ende führen.
Dann können wir genau sagen.
Herr Munchhausen, haben Sie Allergien gegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ich vertreibe mich nicht gut, ich habe viele Medikamente.
Bei der Panthoprazol habe ich auch Probleme.
Ich habe verschiedene Medikamente.
Wie reagieren Sie sich, wenn Sie ein Ibuprofen eingenommen haben?
Ich habe eine Übel mit einem Schwindel.
Herr Munchhausen, brauchen Sie?
Leider ja, das ist noch ein weiterer Punkt, der mir Sorgen macht.
Sie sollen damit aufhören, wissen Sie?
Ich werde es auf jeden Fall probieren, Herr Doktor.
Wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen, haben wir einen Spezialisten, die Ihnen helfen können.
Nach dieser Untersuchung kann ich mit Ihnen eine Termin vereinbaren.
Herr Munchhausen, was brauchen Sie?
Welche Marke oder was machen Sie?
Zigaretten, Pfeifen.
Wie viel pro Tag?
Es wird schon ein Päckchen sein.
Seit wann haben Sie geraucht?
Seit ungefähr 18. Lebensjahr, so bestimmt schon 10, 12 Jahre.
Seit 10, 12 Jahren.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich habe in der Schule, in dem ich letztes Jahr viel getrunken habe, aufgehört.
Da trinke ich fast gar nichts mehr.
Was haben Sie getrunken?
Viel Bier, jeden Tag mit Freunden, 2 Sixpacks pro Person getrunken.
2, 6.
Das war sehr guter Entscheidungen für Ihre Gesundheit.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen damit.
Ich muss eine unangenehme Frage stellen.
Herr Munchhausen, bitte nehmen Sie diese Fragen nicht persönlich.
Diese Fragen gehören zu einem vollständigen Anamnesengeschrieb.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert oder konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Damals, als ich das Alkohol hatte, habe ich auch Drogen probiert.
Ich habe noch Exerzi, Pilen und Cannabis geraucht.
Das war nur 1, 2 Jahre lang, da habe ich aufgehört.
Das ist eine sehr gute Entscheidung wieder.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Nicht mehr, weil ich mich schwach fühle und Gewicht abgenommen habe.
Aber ich habe keinen Sport gemacht.
Wie ist Ihre Familienstadt?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin Single.
Haben Sie eine Partnerin?
Nicht mehr, ich habe mich getrennt.
Ich lege jetzt alleine.
Ich habe mich nicht mehr verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Geschlätswerkern?
Was machen Sie mit der Arsburg-Ruf?
Ich bin jetzt arbeitslos,
durch verschiedene Probleme in letztendlich einigen.
Ich habe früher im Einzelhandel gekauft.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
wurden Sie gegen Corona und Kinderkaterkarten geimpft?
Ja, ich bin nicht geimpft.
Ich habe alles geimpft.
Sie waren in den letzten sechs Monaten ausländisch?
Nein, ich war nicht verreist.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
Ihre Mutter ist Anglioblastome-Multiforme gestorben.
Sie haben Ihre Mutter eine chronische Erkrankung gestorben.
Sie haben eine chronische Erkrankung gestorben.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, Doktor.
Sie hatte keine Krankheiten.
Sie hatte auch Schwere geraucht.
Sie hatte auch Lungenkrankheiten,
COPD, Herzprobleme gehabt.
Sie hatte auch Lungenkriegsbekommen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, Doktor.
Sie haben das nicht mehr ver indicationiert.
Sie haben doch keine Lungenkriegsbekommen gestorben.
Sie haben noch etwas weitergeführt?
Sie haben wichtig gefragt.
Ich wollte fragen, ob Sie denken,
dass man noch mal das CT wiederholen sollte.
Ich würde noch mehr Indiskupinen machen.
Ich glaube, dass ich eine extreme Erkrankung habe.
Körper versteckt bei mir und wollte vielleicht nochmal bitten, dass sie bei mir
einen Gen-Test machen und auch diese Blut, diese Tumor-Maker vielleicht auch abnehmen können.
Ich werde, ich habe ihre Angst sehr gut verstanden.
Zuerst werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen, dann einen Blut abnehmen.
Wenn die Ergebnisse zu mir gekommen sind, dann können wir eine Entscheidung treffen.
Und ich muss auch mit meinem Oberarzt darüber sprechen und ich werde sie gleich informieren.
Wollen Sie noch, wenn Sie eine CD haben, von der letzten CD-Untersuchung, soll ich Ihnen geben?
Ja, wenn Sie es haben, wäre es schon möglich.
Und die Endoskopie befunden auch?
Ja, es wäre schon möglich.
Und die Blutwerte vom Haushalts kann ich Ihnen auch am besten geben?
Aber da waren jetzt nicht die Tumor-Maker dabei, vielleicht können Sie die jetzt nochmal abnehmen.
Wenn es nötig ist, können wir in diesem Prank nach dieser Tumor-Maker veranlasen.
Woran machen Sie das fest, der Doktor?
Ist es nötig oder nicht nötig?
Also, wie ich gesagt habe, zuerst soll ich sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werden wir ein paar kleine Gipfel abnehmen.
Dann können wir diese Ergebnisse einen Entscheidung treffen.
Wenn wieder nichts rauskommt, ich habe Angst, dass man wieder nichts findet und man nicht genau untersucht, verstehen Sie?
Also, Sie sollen nun hier bleiben.
Ich werde Sie ein paar Stunden hier als Gast nehmen.
Dann werden wir darüber widersprechen.
Okay, Doktor, das ist nett von Ihnen.
Vielen Dank.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen eine andere Frage?
Guten Tag, ich habe zwei Fragen.
Haben Sie einen Kaffee-Fleck oder eine Schwellung auf Ihrer Haut bemerkt?
Wie schreibe ich für einen Kaffee-Fleck?
Ja, Kaffee-Fleck oder eine Schwellung auf Ihrer Haut bemerkt?
Ob nichts bemerkt auf der Haut? Nein.
Was ist ein Kaffee-Fleck auf Ihrer Haut?
Wir wollen die Patienten verstehen.
Oder wollen Sie nur wissen, ob er einen Fleck hat?
Ja, vielleicht auch ein Brown-Fleck.
Okay, ein Fleck auf Ihrer Haut.
Wenn Ihr genau guckt, hat er ein paar Flecken doch gerade gefunden.
Könnte auch Melanomen sein, ja.
Nein, hat er aber nicht gefunden.
Gibt es einen Zahn-Hank zwischen Herzklopfen und Stuhlgack?
Hat er nicht gemerkt, nein.
Danke.
Okay.
Weitere Fragen oder Kommentare?
Wo ist die Gurtenrose lokalisiert?
Auf der linken Seite im Brustkorbbereich.
Ist Ihnen Schwellungen nicht genutzt?
Ist der Axel oder im Hasbäer aufgefallen?
Nein, nicht aufgefallen.
Wie ist die Kräbs- und Mutter-Krankheiten?
Genau 5 Reifen.
Also die Kräbs-Krankheiten?
Ja.
Zum Beispiel, die 5 Reifen sind aufgefangen.
Ja, danach hat das angefangen.
Nachdem der Vater tot war, war noch kein Problem.
Nachdem der Mutter tot war, hat das dann kurz später angefangen.
Und nach der Sturbunut, wie viel Mal gehen Sie zum Asch?
Für die Panikatak-Fragen.
Also jede Woche ungefähr?
Ja, jede Woche.
Also beim Haushaltsblut, Ekg-Ultraschall, Langzeitblutokmessung,
Ultraschall vom Bauch, ein krankener aus CT, Sortorax-Abdomen, MRT vom Kopf,
Endoskopie, Gastoskopie, Kuloskopie, das sind die Untersohne, die gemacht worden sind.
Welche Diagnose wurde damals gestartet?
Funktionelle Beschwerden.
Oder Ausstoßtumor, die gestartet gerade hinaus?
Hatten Sie auch 24 Stunden, was der Lasten, die Sammung kontrolliert?
Ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden, 24 Stunden war Urin?
Ja, Urin, Sammung.
Ist nicht gemacht worden? Nein.
Und haben Sie auch Sehstörungen?
Sehstörung, wenn der Herz rasen hat, hat er auch Sehstörungen.
Okay, danke.
Hat Ihr Haut Gerbsucht?
Und auch Ihr Binderhaut?
Auch Gerbsucht?
Keine Gerbsucht, nein.
Okay.
Ich glaube, wir haben ziemlich viel gefragt, oder?
Hat auch viel erzählt.
Dann Vorstellung, ob Ihr Habers oder noch nicht?
Hab noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie erwähnt Kopfschmerzen besonders nach vorne beugt. Wichtig?
Nein, Kopfschmerzen, wenn ihr zu viel mit dem Handy telefoniert.
Ich kann die Strahlung vom Handy kommen.
So erklärt er sich das.
Bitte schön, Furkan.
Hallo Herr Atmaca, ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Darf ich Ihnen vorstellen?
Ja, bitte schön.
Herr Harald Münchhausen ist ein 30-jähriger Patient,
der 70 kg schwer und 175 cm groß ist.
Er hat sich seit drei Monaten, wegen seit drei Monaten
eine gewichtliche Abnahme vorgestellt.
Er hatte viele verschiedene Probleme.
Er hat seit sechs Monaten unter einem Herzrasen
und eine dunkle Rückenchmerzen.
Er hat eine Rückenchmerz, die sich nicht befragt.
Sie haben gefragt, ob Sie diese Fragen stellen.
Sie haben gefragt, ob Sie sie befragen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie diese Fragen nicht befragen.
Er hat gesagt, dass er seit fünf bis zehn Tagen
eine Güterlohose leidete.
Er wurde über eine Hand auf seine Hand gepriben.
Er hat schon sechs Monate bei anderen Arzt gewiesen.
Die Fragen nach FIBA wurden von den Patienten verneint.
Die Vegetative an der Nässe ist auf eine Schweißausbrüche.
Sie hat eine Nachschweiß-Innen-Inapetenz, Verstopfung und Abgeschleunheit.
Er leidete unter einem Kopfschmerzen.
Er wurde bei einer keine Operation durchgeführt.
Er hat eine Medikamente, eine Schausen, eine Traumatur, 500 mg,
einen morgens und abends.
Er hatte keine relevanten Allergen, aber eine Unverträglichkeit gegen Ibuprofen
und Cantabrosol.
Er war vorhanden und war nicht ausreichend.
Er ist seit zehn bis zwölf Jahren ein Pektionssigaretten-Täglich.
Er trinkt heute nicht, aber vorher, als er ein Student war,
hat er zwei bis sechs Päcks jeden Tag getrunken.
Als er ein Student war, hat er ein paar Mal Extasi und Cannabis probiert.
Er macht keine Sport.
Bei der Familienanamnese fanden sich, dass Hermann Schausen single sei
und keine Kinder habe.
Er war arbeitslos und war vorher ein sehr handeskaufmann.
Seine Mutter ist vor einem Jahr angliablösend mit Multiforme gestorben.
Er hat einen ZOP und eine Herzprobleme leidet.
Hermann Schausen berichtete, dass seine Onkel ein Margenkrebs leidet.
Die anamnästische Angaben deuten am ersten auf Depression hin.
Als die Trans-diagnose folgende im Betracht eine Anämie,
Hypertriose, Lungenkarsin, Hochgillenfumme und Hypochondriasis.
Deswegen sollte als erste Maßnahme körperlich untersucht werden.
Bei der Inspektion betrachte würde ich ganz körper betrachten.
Was haben Sie alles schon gemacht?
Ich würde als nächstes eine weitere Abklärung des Masses durchgeführt werden.
Ich würde eine EKG schreiben.
Sie haben eine Differenzialdiagnose gesagt.
Was haben Sie gemacht?
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Sie haben eine Differenzialdiagnose gesagt.
Was würden Sie mir empfehlen?
Sie haben keine gute Lebens.
Sie haben keine Arbeit.
Sie haben viele verschiedene Symptome.
Sie haben eine diffuse Symptome.
Sie haben eine Differenzialdiagnose gesagt.
Sie haben viele verschiedene Symptome.
Sie haben viele Fragen gestellt.
Der Patient hatte eine Herpestoster.
Der Patient hatte sich seit sechs Monaten bei uns wegen der Differenzialdiagnose.
Die Symptome sind nach dem Tod der Mutter aufgetreten oder verstärkt.
Der Patient hatte eine Differenzialdiagnose gesagt.